Europol supports the law-enforcement
community in the member states when you
walk in your own member state you don't
have a view on the information that's
available in other member states it's a
task for Europol to put everything
together to analyze all this information
and to give it back to the member states
so that we can use it in our
investigations in the future it will be
necessary to find the balance between
the needs of the member states and the
needs of a global European approach on
security Europol has to invest even more
in the analytical capacity we have to
put the resources and the knowledge
together to have a strategic view on the
future on what are the threats to the
security of the European citizens the
biggest challenge in my new job will be
keeping the trust in the agency further
strengthen the added value that the
agency can give to the membership and
this balance between the operational
needs of the Member States and the
European agenda on security and the role
of Europol in it
[Music]